[Música]
hay pocas mejores formas de comenzar las
festividades que con música
es el esperado regreso del cine en
cannes y todo comienza en la noche de
este martes el director francés leon
carax fue el primero en subir las gradas
del palacio del festival junto a los
actores adam rivers y marion cotillard
su último proyecto titulado annette
debutó en la ceremonia de apertura su
película es parte de las 24 que están en
la competencia oficial también fueron
nominados tres antiguos ganadores de la
palma de oro el italiano nanni moretti
con tres pisos el francés jacques
audiard com olimpiadas y el tailandés
apichatpong weerasethakul con memoria
otros grandes del cine vuelven a la
alfombra roja junto a ellos está
nominado el neerlandés para volver joven
director de bajos instintos y quien
presentará benedetta la historia de la
vida real de una monja homosexual
ambientada en el siglo 17 y
protagonizada por virginia fira
wes anderson desplegará su universo como
siempre con un casting repleto de
estrellas para su más reciente película
la crónica francesa
si bien las mujeres son mayoría en el
jurado presidido por español y no lo son
en la competencia sólo cuatro están
nominadas entre ellas la húngara ildikó
entendí y las francesas juliá du core 1
catherine corsini y mia hansen-love
estrella americana yuri foster recibirá
un reconocimiento en tributo a su
brillante carrera el festival se
extenderá hasta el 17 de julio cuando se
conocerá la lista completa de ganadores